tout de suite retrouvé notre
correspondante sur place alix le bourdon
bonjour bonjour alix qu'est ce qu'on
peut retenir de cette intervention de
jens stoltenberg
il a redit que l'otan soutenait
l'ukraine mais qu'il n'y aurait pas
évidemment d'envoi de troupes en ukraine
parce que cela signifierait entrée en
guerre directement avec la russie mais
qu'ils allaient les pays de l'otan
fournir une aide supplémentaire à
l'ukraine
en effet un c'est ce qu'on peut retenir
de cette intervention de jens
stoltenberg
le secrétaire général de l'otan il a
plusieurs fois répété que l'otan voulait
soutenir l'ukraine midi là aussi en
effet insisté sur la nécessité de ne pas
rentrer dans une escalade avec la russie
il confirmant ici finalement la ligne
qui a été celle de l'otan depuis le
début de cette invasion russe en ukraine
qui avait vu les alliés refusé et bien
c'est demande de kiev de créer une zone
d'exclusion aérienne il n'y aura pas non
plus a dit le secrétaire général
autant une mission de paix envoyés en
ukraine jens stoltenberg est un qui dit
également vouloir regarder vers l'avenir
pour combattre une nouvelle menace et il
confirme ici lien la stratégie centrale
qui l'avait déjà évoqué hier et ce matin
dans différentes conférences de presse
cette stratégie qui vise à renforcer le
flanc est de l'alliance avec at il dit
le déploiement de quatre nouveaux
groupements tactiques dans les pays
voisins de l'ukraine en bulgarie en
hongrie en roumanie et en slovaquie il a
également parlé de la fourniture
d'équipements à l'ukraine en cas
d'attaqué chimique il l'avait également
déjà évoqué hier et ce matin lors de
différentes lors de différentes
déclarations et puis il a également
évoqué les discussions avec les alliés
dont le but de finalement faire pression
sur la chine pour qu'elle renonce à ce
que les alliés considèrent comme un
soutien politique à la russie oui